[Music]
[Applause]
what is up guys on be showing you how to
do arrows run as a medium level account
super cheap super easy not that hard
let's get started so start out my stats
I'm 74 combat I have sixty attacks 62
strengths 46 defense 81 range 43 prayer
67 magic and 73 hip points
the setup I'm using is 4-0 helm fury
which can easily be changed for a glory
mr. Grove top zero bottom
context kite shield rune eyebolts
ancient cloak open staff you ring of
dueling and I need to go up to combat
bracelet but I want right now and when I
switch to range I use the Catholics
dragon hide ethics chaps rune crossbow
and Ava's accumulator which you can
easily just use black D high chest or
whatever highs range set if you have and
then I have some defense stuff gothic
split League skeptics plate body
berserker helm dragon scimitar dragon
dagger stripped one strength potion for
for prayer pots I normally only end up
using one but it's good to have extra
ones Rose teleports fire ruins death
runes stamina potion and monkfish and
you also want to bring a spade but let
me grab my combat bracelet real quick
and then we will get started all right
so you're going to click the Barrows tab
I'm going to go ahead start a timer and
as you write down here go ahead click
your item bless on
we're going to go to the very southwest
this will be the order I going to I
recommend it but you do not have to do
it so we're going to do Carol so be
ready to pray from range and start
attacking you think mage wouldn't attack
range armor very well but it does very
easily so quickly kill Carol and also
set up your quick prayers I have me Leon
because most brothers are melee
so to quickly kill Carol
you
and now we will go to the middle one and
we have switched to a range because it's
our M or Arab or you say I'm not sure
creaform age and I normally prayer flick
the other brothers other than Carol just
receive some prayer
so just go ahead and turn on Raptor he's
about to shoot is fire wave
you
I'm sure what's your prayer because when
you're in the tunnel Oh boots when
you're in the tunnel it will drop
whenever the face shows up so whenever
the face shows up get ready to drink
potion I'm going to run out here in a
sec the face pops up
you
all right two brothers down now run to
the North East it's Derek
you
Derek it's super high but he'll so it's
slow so you can kind of Prayer flick
them but just be careful because you
move it really high uses max it isn't 60
you
sure to watch your career
all right three down and now we will go
to the northwest corner put on your
armor wherever armor you bring because
Barack hits through prayer normally I
wouldn't even pray against them but
since I have some pretty left over I'm
going to go ahead and do it
see it's through prayer I'm not even
sure if this is you can do anything but
understand keep our possession
you
and now he's dead
I want to go ahead and eat a lobster
you
that's all right
okay so that's where the tunnel is
remember that pops up so that means you
will be the last for the real deal so we
have one more to do
you
so I'm just going to keep creep licking
all them because no sense wasting your
career but Caroline or me just let use
range because it's pretty fast
you
make sure to watch your prayer I lost
out that should be okay
you
all right now it's alright
we go ahead and put on my armor because
I'm going down to the tunnel and I don't
want to get hit
I'm drinking my stamina potion right now
just because I'm going to get to run
around down there okay so when once we
get in here you're going to want to zoom
out as far as you can and go right here
and kind of angle it see how I can see
this door this door and this door so
this is the door that I have to open so
let's see if any of the closest doors
are open they're not so imma have to run
all the way around which is okay
hope is already here
so I try to kill the brothers before my
kill count so I just run around until
they pop up so quickly kill the last
brother they will get our kill count
and now the kill count is very confusing
but basically what I do I just use those
buddy sort of tells me when I'm at a
hundred percent but I would look online
and look at the formulas and see which
monsters depending on your level you
should be killing I normally kill the
lower level ones and then kill a higher
level one here and there
take your strength potion so you brought
it because drops a team then only
brought me 255 strength to so mm don't
be pretty well you can also use range to
kill them my range is higher than my
strength so I use range but melee kills
them faster if you get some good hits
you
let's just arrange a suitable faster
maybe we won't be
you
so you only use one clear pot and one
food but it's always better to be safe
and sorry
you
all right we should have to feel about
two more and then we will run around and
get to the door
if you have high melee just keep using
melee but sometimes I like to use my
range instead because sometimes it's
quicker if Arum drains my stats too well
she drinks to one Martinus
I do on that 98 % infill in law
you
I mean when magic and everything is
pretty low so I mean I'd say I'm a
medium level account and I still do it
very easily very quickly burrows is not
hard if you just have some faith in
yourself a little bit confident now but
in all seriousness Barris is pretty easy
see this guy he's must be bursting them
or just a finding them so one more door
anything it's this one yep
so just run around until you get to the
door if you don't understand the maze I
would look up the maze online but it's
super easy it's just like a big square
basically so now there will be a lock
and these patterns I look up online
because I've memorized them but I would
look them up online and now let's see
what we get it took eight minutes to do
one run let's see we get nothing good
regular blood rooms and I just teleport
clan wars clan wars and to do another
trip all you have to do is go to your
bank
put the runes in and everything that you
want to keep from barrows and then grab
a pearpod
because that's all used and then go here
when to the portal enter it
and then break your tab and then just do
it again alright thanks for watching
guys I'm on 82 chest currently and once
I get to 100 I will be putting on a
video of my 100 barrows chest and do the
math on all the amount of runes I get
and the items I got and then when I hit
100 subscribers I will be doing a
giveaway so look forward to that and
thanks guys for watching hopefully this
helped stay tuned for next video
[Music]